bien sûr aucune naïveté dont dans
l'histoire du rapport à autrui est
d'accord mobilisation des consulats le
désir de dominer le conquérir existe et
il est équitablement distribués
mais les crs n'ont pas commises et les
moins aguerris wolf au passage il son
patron d'axa mais le fait colonial de la
fin du 19e siècle du 20ème siècle s'est
abattue en afrique où les conquistadors
qui sont arrivés en amérique latine je
dois y a des spécificités dans le ton et
son petit côté a relevé son maillot or
justement avec le capitalisme avec la
technique militaire avec les
missionnaires avec les matches il ya eu
l'argent quelque chose de spécifique que
l'on peut réfléchir et penser sans nier
que effectivement pas les rapports
accusent maintenant n'ont pas toujours
été des rapports le p ça se serait su
mais on ne peut pas aussi l'instrument
une naturalité de la production de
l'entretien et du rapport à autrui
il ya du maquereau cohabiter il ya déjà
des coups de mcilroy de velléités
impérialistes à brest au niveau global
et c'est ce qui va nous donner
nécessaire il faut surtout pas en faire
une poudre est nécessaire on est en fait
l'étude de l'histoire
et justement le fait que ben que que
l'on accepte tout ce que tous les
besoins en bois halbout à de
l'autodétermination en droit à profit
gurs et leur destin et que nous devons
sortir deux mondes de la loi du plus
fort je dirais sert progrès comme si un
problème éthique et philosophique et ça
veut dire que ce n'est pas à nous donner
absolument consubstantielle à la à la
cohabitation entre les entre les
humanités et le fait colonial et
lens-caen les effets donc je dirais et
contemporain d'autres faut guérir et
c'est pour ça que ça crédit qu'elle
n'est pas terminée et on pas le ranger
dans les oubliettes de l'histoire
puisqu'on ne peut pas tout lui reprocher
pas non plus d'un revers de la main
faire comme s'ils n'avaient pas existé
comme s'il n'a pas vu le syndicat les
sociétés actuelles et comme si aussi ce
que nous apprend de la colonialité est
pas encore en train de percer ont déjà
présent dans un imaginaire dans une
manière de se mettre hors la changer et
oui il faut bien vivre et c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait une question délicate
mission est simple
[Musique]